I never asked the unions to represent me
they are the ones who requested laws to
give them the right to bargain on behalf
of everyone Kenny Union not only force
people to be members but also spend
their money on issue ads with which they
disagree the United States Supreme Court
is going to take up that issue in its
next term in Friedreich's versus the
California Teachers Association Rebekah
Friedreich's is the lead plaintiff in
that suit and she joins recent TV now
Rebecca thanks for joining us thanks for
having me can you describe the
frustrations that bubbled forth into
this lawsuit
sure so my frustrations began before I
was even a full-time teacher I was a
student teacher and I was learning from
an outstanding master teacher but next
door to us was a teacher who was in my
view quite abusive with her students she
would grab them sort of yank them over
in line yell at them they were 6 6 years
old
first graders and so she just had this
angry look on her face all the time and
these kids were terrified I was 22 and I
was terrified so I asked my master
teacher what can we do about this we
need to let the school know that this is
going on and she sat me down and she
said Rebecca today's the day you need to
learn about teachers unions and teacher
tenure
oh boy so she said you know the district
tries very hard to rid itself of these
sorts of teachers who have become
ineffective in the classroom in this
case abusive but because of teacher
tenure laws they have a very difficult
time ridding themselves of these
teachers so that day I decided I don't
want to be part of anything that would
bring harm to children in that way but
do you have a choice of being part of
that organization in California public
school system I have absolutely no
choice and it's very confusing because
people are told that teachers can opt
out well we can opt out of a small
portion of the dues the overt political
portion of the dues which is about 35%
of our thousand dollars a year the
trouble is that means we are no longer
union
bers so yes I can opt out of membership
but I can't opt out of fees so I pay
what's called agency fees which amount
to about 650 a year in my district for a
for a full-time teacher uh-huh and so
what is this Pacifica this is a First
Amendment challenge
what is the specific First Amendment
claim here so we are arguing based on
our First Amendment rights to freedom of
speech and freedom of association so all
we're asking for it's very simple we're
asking for teachers to be able to decide
for ourselves without fear and without
coercion whether or not to join or fund
a union it's that simple something that
the Supreme Court has allowed to most
Americans and they made this exception
in this the the laws to create something
called labor peace for the labor unions
and for the government employee sector
but it's not very peaceful for those of
us who are forced to fund it so we're
just arguing that it's time for
individual rights to be placed above the
rights of these powerful unions a lot of
people are very upset about this lawsuit
they think you're going to defang all
public sector unions in this country
what do you say to the people who first
were scared about that but second say
hey look you're getting the benefits of
the collective bargaining why shouldn't
you pay for unions won't be destroyed we
think that should we win unions could
actually improve because they would be
forced now to show their membership what
they can do for the membership in other
words they'd have to start serving those
who are paying the bill
I never asked the unions to represent me
they are the ones who requested laws to
give them the right to bargain on behalf
of everyone so I didn't ask for that
would be my first answer my second
answer would be they continue to tell
the American people that they are
offering teachers and other public
sector employees these great benefits
that we should pay for these great
benefits well it is my opinion and the
opinion of
many others that their supposed benefits
are not worth the moral costs let me
give you a couple examples when my Union
goes to the legislature and they bargain
for these Cadillac pension plans on my
behalf
at the expense of our national economy
at the expense of my community I have a
moral dilemma with that I have a big
problem with that now let's take it
another step they go and the Union goes
and they bargain for teacher tenure laws
and now they are protecting teachers who
are no longer effective in the classroom
who maybe are abusive like that teacher
I witnessed at the expense of vulnerable
children who are supposed to be educated
that is a gigantic moral dilemma for me
so I say it's time to set aside this
union name-calling and all this
fear-mongering and let's put America and
her children first and let's put the
rights of individuals above the rights
of these powerful unions there are 20
states or so that had these kinds of
clothes shop laws here you have nine
coplanar nine other teachers involved
yes all California what has been the
response among your peers and colleagues
have you gotten pushback from the unions
you get a lot of like quiet high fives
under the table what has been the
response been like for you personally
you named it I get a ton of quiet high
fives they I only get compliments in a
dark room with the door closed they make
sure there's no one listening Rebecca
thank you we're so grateful to you
thanks for standing up we're afraid that
is what I hear ninety probably 98% of
the time we will watch this with great
interest Rebecca Friedreich's thank you
very much for joining us for reason TV
I'm Matt Welch
you